dr. strange is no one without the
ancient one the character is now known
for Tilda Swinton's gender swapped
portrayal in the MCU but he has decades
of comic book history that predate her
offbeat incarnation a lot of classic
comic book heroes aren't as old as we
think they are storm for example is a
huge part of the x-men but she was first
introduced over a decade after the first
x-men comics at the stands it's actually
pretty rare that the most iconic parts
of a superheroes world are present at
the start the ancient one on the other
hand has been a part of dr. Strange's
story from the very beginning but thank
you ancient one for the ancient one made
his debut in the same story that
introduced the sorcerer supreme
in 1963 strange tales number 110 when
strange visits the master who sits alone
at a hidden temple somewhere in the
remote vastness of Asia later he sends
strange some of his power and with that
their relationship is established old
man and young teacher and pupil a
sorcerer and a successor for a very long
time that first parents gave us
virtually all we knew about the ancient
one
but in 1966 denny o'neil and bill
everett plumbed the depths of this
fathomless soul in strange tales number
148 the origin of the ancient it turned
out that the ancient one wasn't born
magical five hundred years in the past
he was a simple farmer in the Himalayas
living a peaceful
Dilek life but that wasn't enough for
the unnamed youth who had become the
ancient one or his friend kallu together
they would delve into the supernatural
one towards enlightenment the other to
domination and conquest the resulting
conflict would destroy their homeland
and five centuries later they would meet
again to settle their ancient scores
fortunately for the world only one of
them had dr. strange on his side can the
ancient one die it's a tough question
but we've seen it happen in the MCU so
what about the comics is this master of
the mystic arts truly
Mortal in 1973 we found out once and for
all and the answer is sort of death is
already a pretty weird concept in comics
and it only gets weirder if you're an
immortal being whose powers spread
beyond the mortal plane the closest the
ancient one has come was a storyline in
the pages of Marvel premiere that saw
the eltridge being known as shim agora
invading the Ancient Ones mind the
ancient one commands dr. strange to
destroy his mentor's mortal form
condemning him to death while trapping
Shuma graft and saving the world
strange does but then a spectral version
of the ancient one informs his grieving
student that he is more than alive now
that he has become one with the universe
in true comic book fashion death wasn't
the end for the ancient one but his
return to the mortal world was a little
rougher than most in the 1977 storyline
called the return of the ancient one dr.
Strange's all-powerful mentor does
indeed come back to life as a
side-effect of one of strange as many
battles against unknowable cosmic
horrors he's not the regular ancient one
though this time he's back as a
down-on-his-luck alcoholic using his
magic to ensure an ever-flowing supply
of alcohol strange eventually discovered
the ancient one in an alley casting
petty spells on those who intrude upon
his drunken stupor yanked from his
eternal rest in a soul-shattering
transformation disoriented he took
refuge in a mortal shell and drank to
dull the shock of his real Awakening and
maintain his powers naturally dr.
strange saves the day and the ancient
one is able to shuffle off the mortal
coil once more to be one with the
universe but for a moment he had to be
mortal again a despairing all-too-human
mortal without the power of the cosmos
at his fingers it's a lesson he and
strange never forget despite the fact
that the character has almost 50 years
of comics behind him most people will
know the ancient one as an ageless
Celtic woman played by Tilda Swinton
this is not however the only time the
ancient one has made the leap from the
page to the screen
first came in 1978 as part of the failed
pilot turned TV movie version of Doctor
Strange here the ancient one was a
bodyless entity voiced by actor michael
ansara
the ancient one next appeared in 1990s
spider-man the animated series where he
featured briefly in an episode titled
you guessed it Doctor Strange most
recently in animation he was part of the
2007 Marvel animated feature Doctor
Strange sorcerer supreme perhaps his
most notable adaptation however comes
from his place in the Marvel video games
particularly 2006's Marvel Ultimate
Alliance he only appears as a fogged
image in a mirror and strangest sanctum
sanctorum but he actually speaks with
multiple characters too bad for him that
one of them is Deadpool who dead disturb
my meditation crappy is that you so
we've learned that the ancient one is
boundlessly powerful to the point that
not even death has a hold on it we've
learned that he's such a huge part of
steven strangest story that when the
good doctor appears movies cartoons of
video games the ancient one usually
shows up too we learned that his
expertise came at a terrible price he
could never truly repent it's but you're
leaving out the most important part what
haven't we learned his name despite the
many aspects of the ancient one that
have changed with the times
he's never been given a name beyond his
title the Official Marvel website and
comics referred to him only as a youth
and past and the ancient one in the
present whoever he was he isn't any
longer and he's pretty ok with that
check out one of our newest videos right
here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]